freunde erinnert ihr euch an eine zeit
vor instagram als ein gutes frühstück
einfach aus einem pott kaffee und dem
schwarzbrot mit wars wir wissen worauf
ich hinauswill mittlerweile haben wir
smashed avocado brote wir haben experten
entdeckt wir haben die verrücktesten
frühstücks kreation was den titel bestes
frühstücksrestaurant wirklich sehr hart
umkämpft wird es gibt wirklich in köln
unendlich viele instagram track für spot
wo man wirklich kunstwerke auf die
teller bekommt und ich dachte mir was
ist das beste frühstücksrestaurant in
köln und damit herz willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video leute ist war mal wieder
einfach nur ein traum dieses video auf
zu sehen wirklich ihr fragt euch
vielleicht jetzt schon was ist das beste
fürs restaurant laut tripadvisor in köln
jetzt das
neobiota platz 1 michelin stern als
frühstücksrestaurant nichtsdestotrotz
wirklich etwas sehr besonderes in dieser
konstellation wir gucken uns das ganze
84 euro zeichen vier von fünf sternen
platz 195 und 1883 restaurants in köln
mit anderen worten nicht ganz so
eindeutig wie beispielsweise beim
setzkasten weil das war ja wirklich
durchweg positiv gewesen einfach mal
über ein paar bewertung group stockey
zum brunch lesen wir hier direkt in der
ersten festes frühstück in köln gastro
highlight in köln deren restaurant aber
kein stern ist verhältnis ihr seht es
nicht ganz so eindeutig wie beim letzten
mal und umso gespannter war ich als ich
heute morgen hin gefahren bin und ihr
seht jetzt was uns erwartet hat so von
ihr sind wir also mitten in der kölner
innenstadt ich habe mir wie immer nichts
angeschaut zu diesem restaurant da
drüben ist es frühstück 13 uhr war
bisher alles ausgebucht war ich bin tot
hungrig bin gespannt auf das angeblich
beste frühstück in köln wird sagen wir
gehen rein da kann man auch draußen
zwischen hörst schön also richtig klein
richtig kleiner land auf dem stern
bleibt spannend das nächste stern muss
sagen mir dann gerade aus dem urlaub
zurück erster arbeitstag
sternerestaurants co
ganz oft angerufen
dankeschön
[Musik]
allerdings erwartet man zum besten zu
stehen kommt weiß nicht mal ob das
allrad ist auf ihren minuten kriegen
wieder billiger lagen ich habe mich gut
auch als wir angerufen an direkt begrüßt
natürlich andere man also auch wenn das
umfeld sie ist mit stern wenn die leute
trotzdem bei mir direkt ich glaube es
gibt aber auch viele leute
[Gelächter]
könnt ihr einziges abstellen
ok jaletzke machen das sind dann aber
schon kleinere version vom frühstück
oder kriegt man drei monaten okay okay
okay dann gucken wir nochmal direkt
drauf ist was besonderes
formaten
bergmann mit stern vergessen in stories
zu machen ich mach ein foto von der
karte aber an der seite ein case hut und
wie es also auf köln gelehnt mamas
johannisbeere report joghurt creme waren
die bcv leute wirklich trifft schon mal
gut mein geschmack das
nettetaler bänke stolz der green
28 eur 3 gegen könig oder es ist nicht
günstig also so das teuerste was ich
frühstücke mit getränken und so meine
freundin ist so 50 euro das aber nicht
25 personen ja mein der bist du auch
wenn du ein gericht hat nimmt das ist ja
schon für die leute gericht bock haben
sowie eine frage stellen wir identisch
drei so ich gehe auf jeden fall feuriges
dementiert gespräche box und endlich
schlägt das ist so vorstellen dass er
als dritte nämlich die pancakes sagte
die aufgaben und 20 minuten und
zwischendurch nehme ich glaube den
mediterranen bagel mit bratwurst
auch alleiniger dass man instant dry im
gericht zu nennen dem angreifen und das
auch schon mal eins stimmt der und
cappuccino ist natürlich jetzt auch von
dem wir ein fest beste ist dass sobotka
von sein muss und jeder weiß ich bin der
labrador mit erwischen wir können beiden
logischerweise drei verschiedene gänge
wir nehmen aber die gleiche dass wir
darüber sprechen können es wird also
wieder mal der test und der bosse der
bank
super wir wissen auch schon dass wir
essen wollen würden zwar machen wir
beide das frühstücks menüs und nehmen
auch beide das gleiche die reihenfolge
suche und selbst aus oder ok-power sie
kriegen dass eine lieferung kaffeebohnen
werden von anfang an ein liebling der
kontakt zur bedienung glücklich in
andere der republik weil ich manchem
symbol
trade es glaube ich bin im gegenteil ich
bin sehr zu erklären ich habe es noch
nicht gemerkt mussten wir mal sagen das
ist dass wir neben den kaum aus dem
urlaub und ich freue mich und ist klar
weiter zu machen und videos ist auch
krank was im letzten monat ab wie viel
neue abos dazugekommen sind die videos
ankommt ich kenne eure herzen lassen
haben oder wir wollen die eine million
schafft mörder klappt so noch zum 3 4
welcher videos und alle leute fürchten
das tabu
also was man auf jeden fall merkel ist
das zurücklegen und er ist ja positiv
die negativ maschine man hört wie
irgendwas angebraten wird und so das ist
jetzt nicht so dieses relaxing dieses
treiben ich sage ich mal weiß ich auch
dass wir urlaubsgefühl das heißt ja
nicht aber auch frühstück noch
gefrühstückt
haben sie es wird also ein heftiges und
mehrgängiges menü mit einem knackigen
frühstück ich freue mich auf jeden fall
egal ich sage ehrlich das kratzt an der
ganzen sache ist glaube ich dass ein
sternerestaurant stiftung ich glaube das
gibt es eigentlich sonst ja ich glaub
das höchste sondern
ich gehe aber flott ja danke schön
major pluspunkte das noch ein bisschen
kann man hier auch so ist eröffnet mit
zum klappen messer ein dann wollen wir
jetzt mal durch eine schöne kleine
portionen der schaum ist wirklich sehr
schauen
jetzt kommt das wichtigste ist dass ein
das ist explodiert ca das original
explodiert gerade vor
das brot ist ja mal sowas von cross
da kann man aber auch nicht
einzelkomponente probieren eigentlich
nicht diese tomaten schaum hat indes
härtere zum ende hinterher genau genannt
sondern angenehm aber
bestehen wird das ist wirklich komplett
also wirklich sehr groß ich habe bis
jetzt ein leckeres frühstück vorher ja
ich hab noch nicht dieses neben ist ja
da bin ich bei dir da bin ich bei dir
wohnen krass so verwöhnt in diesem
glauben aber erstmal was gemeint von so
diese extra meile habe ich nachts nicht
und deshalb sehr gespannt was man kommt
extrem gutes frühstück
gab es ja gesehen dass so viel schaum
braucht ja trotzdem kommen die anderen
komponenten durch man hat schon wieder
so dieses entspannte so durch das ende
man kann man kommt so wieder so ein
bisschen wie kontrabass snare würde was
bleibt denn jetzt übrig bei dir schärfe
kräftiger automatischer geschmack und
lust auf den nächsten gang dankeschön
als nächstes kommt der bagel troja
dadurch gebrauch macht muss auch mal was
für mich sermeter warum
hatten
ja danke schön
der mann ist
ein richtiger wasserfall einfach mal
siegreich aus auch ein hübsches plating
einfach
nicht so mit der pinzette leben selbst
hat meines wissens prüft oder auch hier
recht viele komponenten jetzt wieder
grüner chance auch wieder zwischendrin
nächstes kommune weiß man dass ich das
probieren möchte wir probieren ist aber
weiß was ich mich edel frühstück essen
ich hasse dass solche sachen mit besteck
zuerst
einen bagel oder sagt eben auch
[Musik]
unheimlich frisch macht folgen auch
wieder sozusagen
das
gemüse ist vor anschließend durchgekocht
bad wo es auch sehr gut gegangen aber
auf jeden fall schon eine steigerung da
finde ich zum ersten aber im prinzip
sind wir mal ehrlich
enttäuscht
ich weiß jetzt schon dass ich hier
wieder verschoben werden erfahren sie
die anderen durch die an und sagt das
schon mal peter pluspunkte und ich find
die portionen dafür dass es kleinere
sind auch gute solide bildet das allein
hätte ich nicht stürze
aus bis zu sagen würde was ist dein
lieblings teil hier aus dem bericht gab
es ein so sind
insekten wie möglich die unterseite ist
richtig schön christi und oben ist es
trotzdem so
jackson
doch ein bisschen blau ist er bisher wir
haben schon recht viel viel bergbau der
so viel gelernt auch das ist eine
bessere politiker immer sind immer mehr
spaß so die sachen auszutesten und
sondern man wird aber auch kritisch für
mich natürlich aufstellen ins büro
worüber tänze oder guten tag haben
eine halbe stunde hier besitzt
beide gewesen also im gegensatz zum
wesen das land auch wirklich eine
realistische sache trotzdem hierhin
kommen schnell setzten die daraus
geherrscht eigentlich die flächen jetzt
schon sehr optische des zweiten tags
also dass in höhe von wien oder 8 und
normalen endlich simon zu hause macht ja
und die sind anders als normale
steckdosen aus nur ein bisschen an
befürchtet dass diese cremes seren crazy
ich würde eigentlich rein das museum
hans beha
diesem gefüllt
ich bin gespannt ich esse einfach nur
die soße weil sie so lecker ist ist auch
gecheckt schon diese gefüllt
dann setzt man wieder zusammen ich hätte
ja auch nicht gehabt war aber sie ist so
wie lucky gesetzes muss sofort für meine
story der gut ist klappt das ist nicht
so dass sie sich das bewegt das ist
normal regeln
halte ich auch aber auch schon wieder
wie auch im setzkasten die schiiten
nicht mit süß das ist nicht einfach übel
sondern das ist sehr ausgereift hier
teilweise auch wirklich drin danach ja
wohl nur mal die spielen also mit den
geschmäckern freude
kraft scheint aber wirklich durch die
kurven perfekt dass die halb gefüllt
sind ändert wirklich alles und das
darauf habe ich gewartet dass er
wirklich ein flash kriegen dass wir so
eine sache zum ersten mal weil das war
alles bis ins letzte detail serie selbst
umgesetzt
diese innovationen an wie jetzt ich
glaube die süße ist eher zweitrangig
warum wegen bse finden sächsische frank
sharry textur bist du da noch
28 euro ein königliches größe kann man
jetzt mal wirklich gespannt was der
ganze spaß kostet durch beide aber das
was für ein erlebniss schon wieder leute
ich muss das ganze sich erstmal setzen
lassen und dann schreibe ich ihr kennt
das ganze meine detaillierte kritik
würde sagen die seht ihr jetzt ich habe
das neobiota zum frühstücken besucht mit
der frage ob dort tatsächlich das beste
frühstück in köln serviert wird ein
spontaner besuch war aufgrund der guten
buchung des restaurants nicht möglich
weshalb wir uns erst um 13 uhr mit
gesteigerter erwartungshaltung zum spät
stück im restaurant einfangen der erste
eindruck war der einer sehr freundlichen
bedienung und eines kleinen hübschen
ladens der zweite eindruck entstand beim
blick auf die frühstücks karte eine
überschaubare auswahl sehr interessanter
gerichte und viele neue interpretationen
von klassikern um uns ein breites bild
zu verschaffen entschieden wir uns für
das frühstücks menü mit drei gängen
gestartet wurde mit dem feurigen
benedikt einer interessanten variation
des frühstücks klassiker experte dick
das eis auf den punkt passiert und die
gesamte komposition war lecker im
anschluss erwartete uns der mediterrane
berge ebenfalls einwandfrei zubereitet
und mindestens genauso gut wie der erste
gang das highlight waren die pancakes
rot und wies mit johannisbeeren aus dem
eigenen garten gefüllte pancake türme
die sehr gut von einer joghurt creme
komplementiert wurden aber sehr wird das
neobiota das beste frühstück in köln
geschmacklich sind einige lokale
konkurrenzfähig allerdings mit weniger
interessanten kreationen ist in jedem
fall ein besonderes erlebnis und einen
besuch wert fünf sterne allerdings ohne
sternchen das war es also vom video
leute danke fürs zuschauen ist mal
wieder mega eismeister test und ich sage
mal so viel in zukunft kommt bestimmt
auch eine folge persönlicher kopf lang
genug gewartet macht's gut wir seinen
job